[Música]
bajo estrictas medidas los restaurantes
abren su interior en nueva york' el
personal debe cambiar su mascarilla cada
20 minutos y lavarse las manos cada 15
además se toma la temperatura de cada
persona que ingresa
pero que los restaurantes regresen no
significa que los clientes lo harán
muchas personas aún tienen miedo de
salir o su economía no se los permite
y para mí es un poco conflictivo estoy
feliz de estar afuera ahora y me
gustaría que los restaurantes
invirtieran más en calentadores y
permitir cenar al aire libre el tiempo
que sea necesario
para quienes están cómodos comiendo
adentro que lo hagan pero para mí la
prioridad es tener a mis hijos en la
escuela para mí reabrir la escuela es
más importante que comer en el interior
de un restaurante
sin nueva york fuera un país sería el
séptimo con más muertes por 19 en el
mundo con 33 mil 153 fallecimientos en
marzo los hospitales y morgues de la
gran manzana colapsaron los restaurantes
ya habían abierto sus terrazas en junio
mientras que los museos que comenzaron a
recibir visitantes en agosto también
abrieron con un aforo del 25 por ciento
no es una reapertura es como abrir un
restaurante nuevo tuvimos que re
contratar personas y entrenar las y
finalmente nos permitieron abrir el
interior
giovanna latas open indoor
tenemos 25 por ciento de capacidad así
que con muy pocas sillas pero es mejor
que nada seeds
las autoridades de nueva york también
permitieron la reapertura gradual de las
escuelas sin embargo el aumento de casos
en varios sectores aún es motivo de
preocupación